[Music]
okay so firstly what's interesting about
this is we're being asked to think on a
premise that oppression or constraint
leads to better art so now what I want
to argue is that there is a worst-case
scenario of this conclusion and a
best-case scenario of this conclusion
the best-case scenario of this
conclusion that oppression creates
somehow greater or more beautiful works
is in its absolute best what it acts to
do within our minds is to make more
tolerable repression and violence
against thinkers who go outside of the
norm and that it's very worst what it
does is it credits the brilliance of
people rather than to the people that
produce those works but to the people
that oppress them so if I can make it
more simple for you it's the equivalent
of us saying that Galileo's work on the
laws of physics were thanks to Pope
Urban because he put him under house
arrest and put him in the position where
that happened it's the equivalent of us
saying that urban and Haytham x'
development of the idea that the ancient
Greeks had is their conviction that
light was shot out by the eyes and
that's what enabled people to see so
even and Haytham when put under house
arrest by the Fatimid Calif s-- at that
time because of being under house arrest
and having a hole in the wall he was
able to fashion that into an
understanding that in fact what happens
is light reflects off of objects and
therefore the eye sees so what we're in
danger of doing is crediting the people
that tighten the constraints with the
brilliance of the people who despite
their circumstances are able to make
great leaps for Humanity so the question
also is is that would these people if
they enjoyed state patronage rather than
state restriction not come out with
equally if not more amazing ideas we see
from history examples of people like
Victor Jara in Chile for it
during the Salvadorian day government
democratically elected government he was
patronized by the state he enjoyed state
sponsorship the music he created was
beautiful and spoke to and for millions
however following the coup on September
11th 1973 backed by the British and US
government and the introduction of
General Pinochet as the ruler of Chile
Victor Jara was imprisoned in Chile
Stadium a long five along with 5,000
other people during his torture he
actually set about writing his last song
which was called Chile Stadium it was an
unfinished work which was smuggled out
of the stadium by a friend of his who
put it into his sock this is a perfect
example of state repression leading to
somebody actually dying so this idea of
oppression creating great work we also
see the the work that he created was
actually unfinished so it's very easy
for us to sometimes philosophize about
situations we have not lived through and
pontificate about the possibility that
oppression or state restriction somehow
leads to greater art so I would say that
is my position for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you